what's going on reject nation greg and
john here we got two trailers to check
out today the tomorrow war
and escape room two so we're going with
the tomorrow war
first i'm excited to check this out why
because um
for the first time in a while i've done
no research on what the hell this move
is about i have no idea what it's about
all i know is uh it was supposed to go
to the theaters
chris pratt hardcore liberal stars in
this movie
and blue state chris that's what he's
known as
i believe on the internet can you stop
this woke chris
the locust of the hollywood chris cut it
out man i really don't care
i think i saw the teaser for this teaser
but i honestly don't remember i might
have just seen an
image on twitter at one point i tried
not to log it so the reaction could be
fresh
and if this video was up on youtube that
means it was private for an hour and
amazon
is cool with it being here so you had
your chance to
block us tent amazon taking your cool
with us right now
what are fighting a war
30 years in the future it's a joke
that's a great joke we
need you to
why fight this happening
if i don't come they're going to draft
you remind us but if something does
happen to me
your mirror will be taken care of if
something happens to you
dude
have jokes in the future
like total recall and from the future
a gauntlet
are you so calm long story yeah
yeah kind of a short story again
of course you are
there's a lot of movie in this trailer
yeah seriously
wow
[Music]
oh my god okay the tones trailer
i call that there's so many tones yeah
they went everywhere in the world and
that
they went everywhere in the world we
gotta get every kind of climate
it's about heartbreak it's about peril
aliens
action adventure apocalypse doom
scary suspenseful horror at the end his
daughter
charming chris pratt charisma jokes in
the future
world war z meets edge of tomorrow uh
with a little of uh you know the day
after tomorrow sprinkled in there
yeah godzilla oh there's so much role in
that work in here
a good role in emerald dad dad
no he's gotta get back to his daughter
he has to do something in the future
because it's gonna affect his daughter
in the past and then she's probably
gonna show up in the future in some
other way shape or form
i'm guessing which is gonna either trip
him out or be really emotional
look guys we don't only cover trailers
here at the real rejects
usually when we cover trailers out of
like the massive ones that people are
blowing up my instagram and twitter
telling me you gotta check this out you
gotta check this out and then there are
other trailers that i wasn't made aware
of until people hit me up saying you
gotta
check this out the tomorrow war and did
i like the trailer
yes i liked it quite a bit and then
there's someone in the comments who's
gonna be like
greg likes every trip well people send
me trailers
people send me something like this is a
cool trailer check it out
yeah rare is the day where someone's
like i just saw the crappiest trailer
you gotta check out and then there's a
bunch of people blowing up my social
media and my messages saying you gotta
check this out
this is a good trailer and i liked it
quite a bit
should rage react from now on and only
cover things we're going to hate
yeah no i thought this was a pretty rad
trailer i mean it is a bit of a sci-fi
salad so in some ways it makes me weary
as to how good the movie itself is
actually gonna be
but uh i mean it's a cool premise i mean
it looks exciting yeah
the visual effects look really cool it
looks insane
yeah absolutely it's like dropping into
the city and people are like
duking it into the swimming pool and
stuff like it looks like a video game
weirdly it looks like the kind of movie
where it's not gonna be
so heavily focused on like okay like
even though he has a daughter and we've
joked already about that like it doesn't
seem like it's trying to come off as
overly serious or important
even though you know it's certainly
going to be grand in the scale of all
the sci-fi action
well here's what i'm honestly thinking
is going to happen when we watch this
movie
i think the movie is going to do that
tone that you're talking about it's
going to be like
taking itself pretty serious i could
just see the rotten tomatoes
just like a very serious sci-fi movie
elevated by chris pratt's charisma
you know that's kind of the vibe i'm
getting from here i think i did see the
teaser for this and i remember thinking
like no no wonder this went to streaming
but then i see this one and i'm like
this
looks like a great theater experience
like the action does look
quite impactful i'm sure jk simmons will
do a serviceable job he's like the king
now he's the great cameo guy now yeah
every every serious cameo guy with the b
when an actor establishes their
longevity and respect long enough then
you get to have a type
i get the impression betty gilpin's
talents will not be put to full use in
this movie because she is a badass
actress who's probably just gonna be the
wife of chris pratt she's a prop to help
us care about chris pratt
like his daughter and hey i'll be i will
gladly admit when i'm wrong but this
looks like a fun mood to do a reaction
to as well
absolutely yeah no yeah this looks like
at least it'll be hopefully
thrilling and have a lot of cool action
and cool yes use of all these different
environments they have on display
the aliens look cool was like wait what
exactly are we fighting just to aliens
just generic aliens right yeah like it's
it's
at least for a trailer sting it's neat
enough to be like oh tentacles
there's also like terminator in here
with the whole time traveling and you
need to pull off yeah you know pull a
warrior from the pieces
like landing on a pile of skulls and
just like all this
it feels hot the landscape looks like i
am legend it looks like like a bunch of
really good apocalyptic films yeah
whatever yeah it's apocalypse salad but
with like a popcorn
it looks like when a video game is
inspired by a bunch of
great apocalypse films yeah yeah yeah
it's like we just wanted to do every
fantasy you've ever had inside that kind
of war
yeah yeah it looks fun man we have a
blast i hope it's good cool
july 2nd america guys what did you think
about this trailer leave your thoughts
down below subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell we'll let
you know if we're going to do a reaction
to the actual movie yeah
we'll catch you chris mckay is chris
mckay the guy did like lego batman lego
batman's christmas
no way a bunch of like adult swim anime
he's done like moral oral and
then robot chicken oh snap why is this
so serious i don't know because i'm like
this is coming from a dude who clearly
has a lot of like broad imagination
all right guys so leave your thoughts
down below we'll catch you guys soon